Career and Technical Education is
enjoying a moment. Governors talk about it
and education advocates celebrate it. Is
this a passing fad or something more?
Our recent analysis of media coverage finds
that CTE has been growing steadily in
popularity over the past two decades.
Since 1998, the number of articles
mentioning CTE has risen more than a
hundredfold and the number of media
mentions has doubled since 2012.
Attention to CTE now dwarfs that paid to
education reforms like school vouchers
or personalized learning. Put in the context
of pop culture, press mentions of
CTE rival mentions of celebrities like
Kim Kardashian, Steph Curry, or Queen
Elizabeth. The rise of CTE is part of a
bigger trend: the increased attention to
skills training and workforce preparedness.
A careful look at how CTE
got here suggests that, for better
or worse, it's likely to remain a focal point
of education reform in the decade to come.
How do you think that America's
schools can best equip students to
succeed after graduation? Let us know in
our poll. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research
and videos from AEI.